we have no representation in northern
rural California that's effective in the
state in a sense the three major urban
areas dictate politics for the entire
state our children are leaving our
economy is crashing we're taxed every
breath we take is regulated and we we
feel that a free state will cure that in
northern california far away from the
hustle and bustle of san francisco there
are a handful of counties that are
attempting to accomplish the seemingly
impossible create a new state the
proposed new state is called the state
of Jefferson
the state of Jefferson will create a
geopolitical area that represents all
the people of northern rural California
and we will be able to use the 10th
amendment to stop federal intervention
in negative ways into our life there
would be less tax and certainly less
regulation and less impact of the agency
and having more states rights we can't
afford to run a California style
bureaucracy that's true but as a small
rural state we don't want to we want a
part-time legislature we don't need 570
plus state agencies we don't need to
regulate the air people breathe I mean
look at this place
we don't need a lot of the things that
California has this is hardly a new idea
the people in this area have been
calling for independence for quite some
time during the 30s there was a cry for
separation and they began to gather and
of course the 20 20 30 clubs from Yreka
took it up and in 1941 in early November
they began to petition for changes and
they that's when you see the the famous
footage from stopping traffic on old 99
and calling for a proclamation of
independence and they had their cries of
the roads aren't passable not even
jackass of all and you know we have
resources nobody wants us to use and we
couldn't even get in and out they felt
that Bo Salem and Sacramento we're
ignoring this region and so they ran a
gubernatorial race and child was elected
they stood on the steps of the Yreka
courthouse and the newsreels came all
the news companies came up and they had
a huge parade and and but this was on
December 4th and of course
December 7th hit and Pearl Harbor and
everything was basically tabled 1941 was
really different they were they were mad
because the state wouldn't build a road
to a copper mine you know this is so
much bigger than that
we already have 350,000 people that want
Liberty we get calls from more counties
every day we're practicing inclusion
this isn't exclusively some right-wing
movement we have we have Democrats
Republicans libertarians independents we
have everyone that wants to see a better
life for themselves and their children
and is willing to to fight for that
liberty this has been done court depends
upon who you read but between fifty and
a hundred times since 1850 and a lot of
people say that's evidence that it can't
be done I don't think so
I think that's evidence that people are
so desperate and so angry that they keep
saying to their legislature over and
over again that it must be done the idea
of separation from California has become
so popular around Yreka that there is a
completely separate group who is trying
their own strategy for separation this
group is working towards becoming a
republic the Republic is is different
from the statehood process in that the
people decide we vote now the reason we
chose the Republic over the statehood is
because we found that we would still as
a state be under the same monetary
system and the same regulations that
exist today we would not be able to get
out from under that so we chose the
Republic form which gives us a true
representative form of government
even though their opinions differ their
grievances are very similar we used to
be known as a tough people we used to be
known as people that could accomplish
anything
I believe we're still those people I
believe that this can be done and not
only that I believe that our survival
depends upon it in rural California we
want to maintain a certain ability to
pursue our own lifestyles it's a
question of can we get away from
California before the debt ship sinks
with all hands on board California has
approximately 1.1 trillion dollars in
debt including unfunded liabilities we
have three representatives where Los
Angeles alone has 35 we're taxed but we
have no say over how those taxes are
spent
we have no representatives at the state
level our voice is irrelevant our vote
is irrelevant and that makes now the
time on June 3rd voters in Tehama County
voted to send the plan to break away
from California to their Board of
Supervisors joining four counties that
have already made the decision to split
and while they've met with little
opposition thus far that might very well
change the closer they get to achieving
their goal of creating their own state